hey guys it's time for the third act
segment and um we don't have an idea for
this segment there's literally nothing
that we can think of to talk about we've
given it absolutely no thought I know
usually I come up with so many ideas oh
yeah and uh yeah my kids went to sleep
my kids woke up my kids it's all about
my kids these days I have nothing else
going on I don't know what else is
happening right we'll get back to us in
20 years you know what I'm just saying
then they'll be doing all kinds of cool
stuff well they do cool stuff now no no
I mean when they're hitting the clubs
and I'm not going to talk to you about
when they're hitting the clubs anyway
can't live vicariously through my
kids I want to know what it's like to be
young and cool 20 years you're going to
be you ever once hit a club I've never
hit a club yeah I haven't either never
once in my life yeah Sona yeah big Club
hitter I was I love the clubs yeah you
actually Sona tore it up back in the day
that's what I hear we talked they
weren't expensive clubs they were you
excuse you right what do you mean Price
Club we know we know people we got a up
places we were cool what do you mean
like what's a good place that you went
what are you do like I would say
something and you would even know if it
was cool or not or was it Club
fantastique was it g was it Club caca
Club caca did you go to did you go to
mudroom did you go to you know jakc mo
joo's where did you go keep going what
else what other clubs do you know uh
oily Sams yeah what about what about
Flop House which was a German club yeah
yeah I went to all those all of those
places um the places where you guys
would stand across the street just like
staring at the people going yeah and
touch and touching
ourselves and pleasuring ourselves with
no with our clothes on and then with our
clothes on just wearing bulky parkas but
just rubbing our chestle areas yeah uh
no no no I was I had no Club life you
know you didn't like dancing don't you
like dancing
um no I never went dancing no Club the
thought of an like after hours thumping
Hollywood nightclub gives me so much
anxiety when I see it in movies It's
upsetting to me okay uh because I can't
I need to Yap I need to talk to people
and I so I also my my only weapon was my
Spiel oh and so the idea that you would
take that away with loud club music no
you would also you have money that you
could get a nice table in the middle of
the Dance Floor no now I do but for
years I didn't oh I guess for years I
was you know driving a 77 Isuzu opal and
wearing clothes that I had worn in high
school that I had stolen from my brother
Luke and then and then I'm going to be
in the and you know like waiting for my
skin to clear up I'm going to be and you
know you and Greg and Rodman and you
guys never just like went out and if you
ever yeah if you ever want to know what
the opposite of Entourage
was like literally the negative image of
Entourage it was my posy in the late my
posy in the late
80s hey is there do you have a gluten do
you have a gluten free
bun is there a gluten-free bun the
opposite of water absolute
opposite son you probably noticed that
Envy can actually be a motivating force
that inspires people it could I guess
like you probably come in every day and
look at me and go wow I envy being Conan
OB Brien not at all not even in the
slightest the looks the talent that head
of hair nopity nopity
Envy is commonly regarded as a vice but
it can be a good thing Envy can be a
catalyst for creation inspiring the
world to raise the bar and Angel's Envy
is a bourbon that is worth the Envy okay
so that's where we're going with this
that's where it ended up I was wondering
where you were going you had right ahead
I would have known Angel's Envy is
finished in Port barrels that's the key
which adds a layer of complexity to the
whiskey and gives it a unique and
approachable flavor whether it's for
someone special or to bring to a
housewarming party a Angels Envy makes
the perfect gift with its unique bottle
design Angels Envy bourbon finished in
Port barrels is sure to be the Envy of
any bar cart too look for Angels Envy
bourbon finished and Port barrels please
drink responsibly copyright 2024 Angels
Envy bottle by Louisville Distilling
Company Louisville Kentucky there was a
place here in La when we first moved out
here called flaky Jake oh I remember
that place a restaurant it was a
restaurant but what you did is you got
like a tray and you built your you built
and and my friend Greg figured out he
was like we got to go to flaky Jake cuz
he figured out you
could you could just buy the hamburger
bun for like 30 cents and then you could
take it through the salad bar and just
pour a salad in between the two buns and
make a sandwich that cost basically 35
cents that was made of stuff at a salad
bar and he would he would eat it and
just be like man we got the system beat
and this was my wingman yeah this was my
wingman hey L
[Music]
ladies who wants to go out you want to
go out to dinner sure you guys seem cool
we'll go out to dinner with you all
right we're going to flaky
Jake and dinner is on us there's two of
you so that's 60
cents Greg gets one bun I get the other
bun who wants Ranch now who wants french
on top of Ranch now who wants croutons
on a bun now who wants klaw on that oh
my God say it all the same I would way
rather do that then go to a club no joke
clubs give it just gives me severe
anxiety or something I like letting
loose I like just going Place someplace
and just like having drinks with my
friends and just like letting loose it
was nice I had a lot of fun I had but
also you're a very uninhibited person
like you were and this is not but you
were someone who you could meet a fella
and then be making out with him on the
dance floor and that was no problem sure
yeah you weren't afraid of a little PDF
you know
PDA PDF is a
document what I'm saying is you were not
afraid you were not afraid to call up a
document on your screen in a loud club
with a guy you don't really know my God
you weren't afraid of a little Microsoft
X were you you had some time for a Pages
duck or let's say an adobe Photoshop
jpeg on a hot night maybe even a gift
woo I yeah no I did I that's how
unfamiliar I am with a PDA is that I
call it a PDF yeah but what I'm saying
is I've you know used to come back you
know when in the early days when you
were you would come back with stories
yeah yeah yeah and I'd be listening like
they were ghost stories I was like oh my
goodness I actually put on pearls so I
could clutch them oh my no you're right
I think yeah you and I are different
that way right that you enjoyed life no
it's that you know I'm you're you're a
lot more you know just
like well those are just noises you're
not saying words know but I mean you
know yeah you're a lot more buttoned up
than I am which is I think good I think
I was a little too much to the extreme
you were a little extreme but also I had
my time I had my time let's just say I
had my time okay you pdfy Jakes you
brought a pdfy flaky Jakes there was a
period where I briefly got it together
okay okay it was basically during the
first George Bush Administration I see
all right leading into the early Clinton
administration okay see I was quite a I
mean yeah niame now now my my my
definition of got it together is
probably different from your no but
still you got you went outside your
comfort
zone um sure okay yeah what did they
call you in that period um they called
me the red rooster oh
God that's sexy that's not sexy red
rooster uh that's not sexy it's okay why
not just like the that's too
obvious it's just too there was a writer
knows I'm talking about the Gen there
was oh okay all right no then that's
okay there there was there was a writer
on our staff once who was sort of
bragging about how he was quite the
Ladies Man back in the day and I said
yeah they called you jack
I just cuz I just thought it was such a
ridiculous man what are you jack
what a ridiculous nickname for a
ladies man to God I just love that you
think have to have a nickname yeah I
went by Bill night
sex good okay that worked out well for
you that's why you were sweeping up at
flaky Jakes shout out to flaky Jakes you
think they're still in the business no
but there is an abandon flaky Jakes I
think in like off the 60 freeway yeah I
bet it's haunted I bet ghosts are making
sandwi for 60
cents we getting away with
murder